we're not going to talk
about a very important topic in building
prediction models
which is validation
the basic idea is this um the goal
when you're building a model a
prediction model of some kind your goal
is
not to predict the outcome on the given
data
uh after all you know exactly what the
outcome is so you don't have to do any
prediction at all or rather you have an
excellent
prediction of it so in fact what it's
really about
is you really want to be able to predict
the outcome on new unseen
data so or for example you don't want to
build a
i mean you might want to build build a
model but you really want it to work
next week that's it that that's that's
basically the idea
okay now a model that makes reasonable
predictions on new
unseen data um is it said to
generalize well in other words it worked
well on the data
i used to build the model and now it
generalizes to this new data which it
has never seen before
now if it fails to make good predictions
you would say that the model is
suffering from
over fit uh although there are a couple
of other reasons why the
the the um it may perform uh poorly
okay so this is the actual goal
so a very simple way uh to
simulate how the model will really be
used in practice
is is called validation and so the way
that works
uh is it's really very simple um
and it looks like this you have you're
given an initial set of data
and what you do is you you remove part
of that data
uh people often just choose uh you know
like 20 of the data or
something like that 30 10 and they hold
that data which you really know that you
know that data you know the values of
white
and you kind of you put that aside and
you kind of hold it in escrow so it's
just sitting there waiting
then what you do is you build the model
or fit the model and
the slang uh term for that is to train
uh the model um on the training data set
that's the data from your data that you
did not hold in reserve that of the
stuff you're holding in reserve
is is called the test set uh or
validation set
um so what you do is you you train or
fit the model based on your training
data and then what you do is you now do
a very good simulation of what you
really want the model to do which is to
see to is to work well on data it has
never seen and so what you do now is you
take the data that you have
but which you did not use to build the
model that's the test data
and you simply try your model on that
and then you could then you know because
you know what the actual outcome is
you know what the outcome is and you
also have you have a y and you have a y
hat
and now we can assess how well we did so
that's the idea i mean it's
actually a very simple uh idea
and so you could do several things here
uh one is you might check the rms
prediction error on the training and
test sets i mean
it would make you feel uh very confident
if they were about the same you would
you would not expect them to be the same
but you'd expect them to be about the
same
typically you might expect that the test
data rms error to be a little bit worse
um actually sometimes it's much worse
but okay
the important point here is that it's
actually the date the
rms error on the test data which really
matters sort of in practice
right um now if if this all tests out
um you can guess the model will
generalize now that's not a guarantee
by any means but it's it's a good guess
right so if you go to someone and you
say i'm able to predict demand for this
product uh one week ahead
i can get it basically around plus minus
five percent
and then someone would say well how do
you know that
and the answer would be something like
well i did it very carefully i i took
all the data from the last two years
i took the last you know i took the
first year and a half of that data
and i used that to build my model and
then i took that model and i tried it on
the last six months of data
which might which that when i trained or
fit the model parameters
well i never used never saw that data so
that's as if
that's actually an honest test because
it's actually testing of it
and then you'd say and you know and
there i do plus about plus minus seven
percent
and that would be a very happy outcome
and then someone would say to you well
uh how about next year how do you think
you're going to do there
um the answer is a bit tricky you could
an honest answer well you could say
something like this well i would
guess or expect to be around
plus minus seven percent right that
that's reasonable
um and they'd say but can you guarantee
it and the answer is no you can't you
absolutely cannot
so okay um i should say that you'll see
all of the topics we're going to talk
about here um in a you know from a
different point of view and
much more technical detail in a
statistics course or machine learning
course
but the ideas are all accessible even
without those concepts
okay so validation is actually super
useful because it ends
arguments about uh you know which model
is better
right so if you have you have two
competing models and in fact it's very
common for people to produce
50 or 60 different competing models uh
we'll see a lot of that later
um and then the question is which is
better
example would be should i fit some data
with a polynomial of degree
3 or degree 8. and
so the point about that question is it's
not it's nothing you can answer by
looking at just
the training data alone absolutely
nothing because the degree 8 polynomial
model
is going to fit better than the degree
2. does not mean it's going to fit
better on next year's data or whatever
you know future unseen data
so uh that's kind of the the idea
there that this sort you also have
radically different types of models and
you would say you know should i use this
model that model
and this would actually validation would
answer that question
right so and you'd use what you do is
among all your candidate models
you'd use the one that has i mean the
traditional the simplest way to say it
is the one that has the lowest error
but you might also factor in other
things like all other things being equal
you probably want the model to be simple
right so for example if a whatever if a
10th order polynomial model
gave you the slightest improvement in
the test error
over a cubic you'd probably choose a
cubic
okay so as i said in other courses
you will see this treated in more detail
and things like
that more formally okay so let's look at
an example
um so you'll we there's a hundred
we there's a hundred data points
actually 200 100 of them are the
training set and we use that to fit
a quadratic a a degree 6 polynomial
a degree 10 and a degree 15 polynomial
now what's showing here
is another set of 100 data points which
is the test
data point and actually just if you run
your eyeball over it
looks pretty good i mean you know this
is um and it's honest right that that
here those that blue curve is making a
prediction
on data it has never seen before so
it's actually it's an honest simulation
of how what you want a prediction model
to do
okay this is sort of a typical uh yeah
this is this is a typical situation so
here for example
i have an increasing degree in my model
now by the way
a a model of degree you know 10
is also a model of degree 15 because you
just the last five coefficients you just
make them zero
what that tells you is this is that the
as the degree increases your training
error
just gets it just goes down it gets
better and better because
well i it could also stay the constant
right because the point there is if i
can fit something
with a you know a 10th degree polynomial
um i can't fit it worse with a 15 degree
polynomial i can only do better
okay so the blue curve here shows you
the training error and sure enough it
just goes down now
a lot of times common sense tells you
that what you're looking for is the
i guess that's the traditional knee of
the curve knee of the curve means
something around right here where the
marginal improvement
it is not is not it is not good okay
so um but validation makes this pretty
clear
so the red shows you the performance of
the model on data it has
not seen okay and let's see what that
looks like
well for order uh zeroth that's a
constant model by the way
one two three four it's pretty close um
and what you see though is very
interesting
uh the sixth order sixth degree month
uh sorry seventh degree model is
actually
is actually worse on the test data than
the sixth degree
so um that's not something you could you
could guess or know i mean you just
simply have to try this with the data to
see
to see to see that and it's pretty
simple you know you can understand why
and out here it's like considerably
worse
right so that here uh if i fit with a 20
degree polynomial i
have an rms error uh of you know 0.2
whatever 0.21 right on the training set
and yet on the test set i'm almost
double that at 0.4 right so the
old-school rule of thumb might be to say
you know
it's orders it's degree six that has the
lowest
test error but honestly uh you know
degree
four looks pretty good to me too and the
reason is
it's not a whole lot uh it's not a whole
lot worse than that and it's a simpler
model so
okay so this is the idea this these are
very important things you're going to
see this in other classes or you may
already have seen in other classes but
you get
you will see this in other classes let's
just leave it that way
okay now um that
validation also called out of sample
validation right um
uh there are many variations and
extensions on it
um and i'll just mention one other one
and this is another one probably the
second most widely used it might even be
the most widely used cause
cross-validation
and it goes like this i mean so this is
how it works for
is what you do is you take your original
data and you divide it into ten groups
by the way very often this is done
randomly so you just you randomly
take your data and assign them to 10
different groups
then what you do is the following for
and these are called folds of data what
you do is
uh for each for i equals one to ten you
you fit a model using all the folds
except the ith one okay and then you
test that model on the i fold and so
this is an honest test in the sense that
you are building a model based on some
data
and then you are evaluating on data it
has never
seen which is after all what we want a
model
to do so so here you get 10 different
honest tests of your model honest test
means
you are trying it on data it has never
seen
okay so this is very common uh five-fold
it means you do this and you chop it
into five parts ten-fold
and by the way there's lots of other
methods but these are these are kind of
the ones you might hear about the most
um now it also it's actually also
very good uh sort of engineering because
you get to check
do some common sense checks um so
you get to see the what you do is you
look at the test rms errors and if
they're much bigger than the trained rms
errors
it that's a that's a red flag um
the other thing is you can you can look
and see if there if the test and
training rms errors are consistent
um then that that allows you to guess
with considerable confidence that it's
going to work that that model is going
to work similarly in the future
it's not a guarantee so i remember once
in class i
i asked somebody i remember asking uh i
i said
someone like oh but that would never
happen right i mean you're you're you
know once you do cross-validation
your mouth's gonna work right and it was
silence and then
somebody raised their hand and said no
that could happen
you could do full cross validation and
and then all of a sudden your model
could work very poorly and i would say
well what would you do
when the ceo comes into your office and
pounds the desk and says you know do you
realize what the consequences of this
are blah blah blah
and uh and the student uh looked up and
just and
and the ceo screams and says what
happened and then
the student just looked at me and said
things changed
so that simple right so if you're making
a model of like
for advertising or demand of a product
or anything
anything involving kind of people and
social systems and economic systems of
course they can change
right newtonian mechanics by the way
doesn't
change that often but okay another story
let's look at an example and just see
how this works so
this is a super simple example right but
nevertheless it's going to show you how
this
works so this is this really dumb thing
where we are going to predict
house price in thousands of dollars
based on
a mere two features which are the area
uh in thousands of square feet and the
number of bedrooms
okay and we took 774
houses this is in some place i forget
where
uh over some time period you know not
expanding you know like 10
not not covering tens of years but you
know maybe a year or something like
that um and that was divided into five
folds of 155
sales each completely just at random
okay
then let's look at what we did so in the
first one
we tr we removed fold one that's 155
houses house sales we removed it built
it on the remaining whatever 774 minus
155 so 620 odd you know about 620
things that's how we fit our parameters
of which we have three by the way we
have
the offset we have beta one and beta two
these are very very
elementary simple models right um okay
and here are the results these are my
three parameters
that's my training test and that's my
test
sorry that is my training rms error and
that's my test rms error
this is exactly what you'd expect you'd
say whoa it's 74 and then on the test
you don't expect it to be as good as the
train or whatever
but same ballpark um so you see 7178 and
you go
yup that's a that's good but if someone
says look
before we put this model into production
i really need to be more confident than
just this right you know
okay so then what you do is in fold two
we remove a different 155
ones it's full we remove fold to fit the
model and here's what we get
and you know what's kind of cool is the
parameters are not the same
but they're kind of in the same ballpark
which is which is also
good sign here the training
rms error is 75 which is like okay this
is
by the way if these were exactly the
same you'd be suspicious right you'd say
it doesn't look right and here oh this
is interesting look at that
on the test rms error on this second
model
is actually better than the training one
and can that happen and the answer is
sure and if someone says
how did that happen i think the answer
would be luck
right so basically what happened was you
fit a model
you applied it to you used it to predict
the prices of houses unfold too and for
whatever reason
that was a set of 155 houses that were
where our model was
he's was reasonably uh good at making
the guesses and so we actually did a
little bit better
and look at that you know so you keep
you you go on and you kind of get the
idea
actually the test set did better a bunch
of times you know
usually this is because there's some
hard to fit
houses and maybe if they land in the
training set that's cool and if your
test set is more benign you do well but
but this gives the idea and this gives a
whole lot of confidence in
in this model right and so based on this
you would say
um oh by the way based on this you could
go back and
re-fit based on all the data
right or you could just choose any of
these i mean it wouldn't matter but the
point is that the offset should be on
the order of
i don't know 55 i mean i'm just making
that up right something like that
beta 1 clearly should be on the order of
i don't know 150
beta 2 is like you know i don't know
minus
19. i'm just making this up right um and
we could expect
a test error that is somewhere in the
range of you know
70 to high 80s and perfectly reasonable
we would not be shocked with any of
those numbers if if we use this model to
predict
housing price other houses house prices
this this would be sort of our
confidence
okay so this is just an example of
five-fold cross-validation
the last topic we're going to talk about
very briefly
is is the so-called feature engineering
it's a way to interpret
those basis functions that we talked
about
earlier when when we started and it's
also a a very important thing in fitting
prediction models is so called feature
engineering i'll i'll show you what that
is
this is just just just a hint of what
feature engineering is as you know
you'll
you will see this in other classes
internships
whatever you're going to see this so it
but this is not a bad time to sort of
explain the basic idea
okay so basic idea is this is you'll
start with some original or base feature
x right that that's the actual like raw
data that you have
right um then well as
as this whole chapter started the key
was to choose these basis functions
and one way to think of them is that
they are
mapped or uh it's a transformation on
the original stuff and maybe sometimes
the transformation is very minimal
for example in a regression model pure
regression model
the transformation is we take your
original x and we
add a new feature which is one in front
of it so that that's very benign but it
can also get real
weird and crazy uh what you do in in in
these mappings right
once you've chosen these what you do is
of course you fit a model
this way and then of course and this is
always the case
you check the model using validation
period no one wants to hear you'd say if
you'd say how's your model you'd say
oh awesome you know i have this rms
error and they say
so basically it would be expected you
would report to another person
the test rms error or out of sample rms
error or cross-validated rms
error something like that right not
certainly not the train because no one
cares about the training
error basically okay so
i'll just mention a couple of things
that people do
to transform features um one and this is
very common
now again this is not you know central
to this course uh this is just that
we've arrived at a point where you can
actually do some like pretty cool stuff
i mean like actually very powerful very
cool stuff
one is called standardizing and that
does nothing but take your original
features
and then it it offsets it and scales it
the idea being that you would like your
features to kind of have a range from
minus one to plus one
i mean roughly right so that is actually
uh maybe almost universally done uh in
in when you're using these types of
models right is
you would do that and these new
standardized features are are called i
mean they're approximately standardized
um they're called z scores not
surprisingly right and now they're
completely interpretable
right so so if z3 equals
0.2 it means that the third feature is
a little bit above the mean that's what
it means if it's minus 2.5
it's surprisingly below the mean like a
kind of a one in 100 kind of thing below
the mean that's
all um okay here's another trick
if x i is not negative and spans a wide
range you replace it with a log of one
plus x i
so i i'll give you a couple of examples
of this um
well here's one um well actually we
could start
here here's one things like this often
counts like
the count of how many people listen to a
song or how many people
uh bought a product um some products
have sales measured in like you know
five ten
right others you've moved like you know
350 000 or something like that and so
these when the
when the xi's span this huge range like
that it's very common to take a log or
log one plus
x uh to to just get the scale uh
right right so that's a that's a that's
extremely common
uh in this and that that's that's just a
log transform
um you can create new features
um by uh as functions
of the existing features now we've
already seen that because that's one way
to think of what a pollen what a
polynomial thing does right
uh you know in a polynomial when we do
polynomial fit
the raw feature is a single is a scalar
it's just it's a number
then we tran you can think of it we
transform it right you know
f1 gives you one f2 gives you x
f3 gives you x squared that's like a
transform and
x cubed and so on so that that's how you
think of a polynomial
um model but you can do other cool ones
like here's one
is you take here i'm taking the first
raw feature
i subtract b and and i take the max of
that and zero and so i get a kind of a
cool thing
so here's here's b um and so
it just simply looks like this right
it's uh it's the max it's
it's this function here it goes there
and then and then there
right and so this new feature if x1 is
less than b
it's just zero right above b it gives
you the amount by which it's above b
and that's a that's a that's a you call
that the high feature
right um by the way uh this is useful to
do in conjunction
with standard standardization so if you
do standardization
a a good number for b might be 1
or 1.5 and you'd say that's a feature
which is almost always zero
but basically what it does is it tells
you the amount by which b is real
the original feature is really large and
you could do the same thing with min
i won't talk about that so
now we'll do an example um and you know
we're going to predict house prices
and you know it's a it's you know this
is a very simple thing but i'll
i'll start with the raw uh the base
features so the base features we have
about
we have four um i should say that you
know when people actually predict house
prices it's not based on four
raw features it's based on hundreds and
hundreds right just
tons of stuff right so these are highly
simplified but at least this model will
not be as uh as
as extremely simple as the other one
where we're predicting it based on the
house
area you know and the number of bedrooms
okay so
okay so here it is x1 is the area of the
house in thousand square feet
x2 number of bedrooms x3 is what people
would call a boolean feature
so it's either got the value 1 means
that
that's a condo actually a condominium 0
means it's a house
x4 is the zip code now that's
that's uh that's interesting right so
it's a five digit
integer it's a it's a zip code um and it
there's 62 different zip codes
okay so x4 is again you don't need to
know this
but it's what you call a categorical
feature meaning it only takes a finite
number of values in this case 62
different
zip codes okay so we'll
do uh we'll use eight basis functions
uh i'll say a little bit about you know
how do you come up how do you do this oh
by the way the act
of taking raw features and coming up
with these
these feature mappings or basis
functions fi it's called feature
engineering and it's probably one of the
it's it's like
in someone in some sense that's that's
sort of the essence of building models
okay so we'll use f1 of x equals one
that's a constant that's an offset
feature
f2 is x1 which i believe is just the
area of the house
f3 is interesting it's the max of x1
minus 1.5
and 0. so f3 is a feature that is
the number of thousand square feet by
which your house area
exceeds 1500 square feet that's what x3
is so
x1 that is indeed what x3 is sorry
yes the the f3 of x is that
the transform feature is uh i guess we
call that x tilde three anyway whatever
it is
um so it tells you that so it's zero for
small houses and for big houses might be
big
okay um uh f4 is simply going to be the
number of bedrooms
um f5 is going to so these are very
simple in code in
encodings or feature mappings or
engineering right so
i just use uh i'll just use the boolean
as it is
um f six seven and eight they're boolean
so they're either zero or one
and what they're going to do is they're
encode four groups of near of zip codes
so in other words we take the 62 values
of zip codes
we divide that into four like
neighborhoods and then
what will happen is each of these
will be zero one and that will encode
which neighborhood you live in
okay we do fivefold model validation
and here are the results um so we have
uh
eight parameters in in this in this
model it's slightly
you know it's a bit more complicated uh
and and here are the so the first thing
you do is pretty cool the first thing we
should do is look at
this table here um so
the you scan down the train thing and
you get different
training rms errors at like 67 you know
up to 70. and that's that's good
um okay and you look at the test the
cool thing is that the test is
it's not hideously off from the train
it's in the same ballpark
a little bit bigger for sure a little
bit bigger right like look at that guy
right there
of course there's here's a time when you
were super lucky um
but the point is it's in the same
ballpark and so i think what this would
tell you is that you
this model i could refit the model on
all the data
and i i could make a pretty good guess
that for houses you have
never analyzed you're gonna get it
probably with around an rms error about
whatever it is uh on the order of 70.
okay so
um that's uh that that's what this shows
uh you can also look at the coefficients
and you'll and what you see is
is actually kind of encouraging it
basically says that the coefficients
are what people call stable in other
words that
you know looking at different folds of
the data you don't get exactly the same
parameters of course
but they're you know they're kind of
stable like you know you just take a
look at this one
you'd say well okay that's that's
there's no true value of theta seven
that's ridiculous right but the point is
this says that we consistently
assign a value of around i don't know
minus 109 or eight or something like
that two two
two theta theta seven okay so this is
the i
this is the basic idea and this would
show you how you might do it in some
real setting
now in a real setting you would it
probably much more complicated and you
wouldn't have
eight parameters you could easily have
800 or 8 000 parameters
um oh one last thing
is you could reasonably ask like how did
you come up with this
like and i'll and here i'm just going to
tell you the truth um
by fiddling around okay so that's how it
was done
uh you just try to you try a couple
things oh
very important point about that which is
a part that you do we do not apologize
for
and that's this um you might try
50 hundred different weird candidates
like for example over here
why 1.5 why not one why not 0.5
why not two so the way you do that
is you just try it you build it and then
you do five-fold cross-validation
and you see which which of your 50
different uh attempted models has the
best
five-fold test error or simply the best
test error out of sample
and that's your candidate so in this
sense you let the data tell you
which model is the right one right and
by the way if it's not a whole if it's
not a whole lot better than a much
simpler model you kind of go with the
simpler model right
so i didn't mention that but i do want
to mention that's about now here you can
see that
we're getting test errors in the 58 to
70 range
it's fine right but let's go back and
look at our really simple model over
here
here you go and here's what you see
these numbers are definitely larger
period
right so so our other conclusion from
this analysis
is that all of this feature engineering
that we did
here actually did something we came up
with a better model
so now whether or not this is
sufficiently better to justify this
crazy
model it's another story and
i guess that story depends on what
you're going to do right in some
applications
uh it's important that the model be
simple because you have to explain it to
somebody for example possibly a
regulator or somebody like that who you
know needs to know
what are you doing and how are you doing
this um or
uh to take another example it could just
be like some crazy hedge fund where
you i couldn't care you couldn't care in
the slightest
what the what the model means what
you're interested in is does it make
good predictions
of the way prices are going to move and
if it does
we'll use the model and we don't care
what it means so lots of variations on
that
you